nous entendons à présent madame Sylvie
Lemay qui est candidate proposé par le
gouvernement aux fonctions de président
du conseil d'administration de l'Agence
nationale de santé publique plus connu
sous le nom de santé publique France en
article de article l14 51 terrain du
code de la santé publique sa nomination
doit être précédée sur une audition par
les commissions compétentes du Parlement
sans que celle-ci soit suivie d'un vote
simplement une audition je vous précise
que cette audition fera l'objet d'une
captation vidéo retransmise en direct
sur le site du Sénat et consultable en
vidéo à la demande je vous rappelle que
santé publique France a un établissement
public à caractère administratif placé
sous la tutelle du ministère charge du
ministre chargé de la santé l'agence a
pour mission l'observation
épidémiologique et la surveillance de
l'état de santé des populations la
veille sur les risques sanitaires
menaçant les populations la promotion de
la santé la réduction des risques pour
la santé le développement de la
prévention à l'éducation pour la santé
la préparation et la réponse aux menaces
alertes et crise sanitaires et le
lancement de l'alerte sanitaire ce rôle
a été chacun s'en souvient
particulièrement mis en lumière à
l'occasion de la crise épidémique de
covid-19 pendant laquelle l'agence a
d'ailleurs reçu plus de
a reçu plus de dotation exceptionnelle
qui ont porté son budget jusqu'à 5
milliards
je vous propose de débuter cette
position par un propos liminaire dans
lequel vous pourrez présenter votre
parcours ainsi que la vision que vous
avez de votre futur mandat à la
présidence du conseil d'administration
de santé publique France vous pourrez
notamment développer la manière dont
vous envisagez la place de l'agence dans
le paysage de santé publique ainsi que
vos relations avec sa direction générale
élément de la commission pour ensuite
vous poser leurs questions madame mais
je vous souhaite la parole merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente
la présidente Madame la rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs les
sénateurs
ma candidature à la présidence du
conseil d'administration de santé
publique France qui vous est proposé par
le gouvernement me vaut l'honneur d'être
entendu aujourd'hui par votre commission
et je m'en réjouis
c'est aussi un grand honneur de me voir
proposé pour cette fonction auprès d'une
des plus grandes agences par son
périmètre et par l'étendue de ses
missions donc je suis très heureuse
d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui
votre commission a une bonne
connaissance des missions et du rôle de
santé publique France vous les avez
rappelé madame la Présidente et votre
commission a produit de nombreux travaux
et on a commandé d'autres dont la Cour
des comptes sur les enjeux sanitaires et
les enjeux majeurs de santé publique de
façon générale
dans l'écosystème des agences sanitaires
et comme vous le savez santé publique
France et la traduction d'une volonté
qui est née en 2016 de doter notre
agence de notre pays pardon d'une agence
de santé publique forte scientifiquement
et surtout incarnant un continuum de la
connaissance à l'action de la
surveillance à la prévention
c'est une agence scientifique qui
éclaire les décideurs apportent son
expertise y compris à d'autres
institutions et contribuent à soutenir
le système de santé en particulier à
travers la réserve sanitaire et la
gestion pour le compte de l'état des
stocks stratégiques via l'établissement
pharmaceutique
elle collabore étroitement avec d'autres
opérateurs dans le domaine sanitaire
dans le domaine de l'environnement et
dans le domaine de la recherche
enfin santé publique France s'appuie sur
un réseau territorial les cire qui sont
hébergés par les ARS car la veille et la
prévention l'égard des populations
doivent se faire avec les acteurs au
plus près du terrain
alors le mandat de la présidente du
conseil d'administration de santé
publique France n'est pas une fonction
exécutive celle-ci est exercée par la
directrice générale Caroline semaille
que vous avez eu l'occasion
d'auditionner en février dernier à
l'occasion de sa nomination
alors c'est sur la base de mon parcours
et de mes diverses expériences dans le
champ de la santé et de l'environnement
de ma pratique de l'interministériel et
de ma connaissance des rouages
budgétaires et de l'État que je suis
aujourd'hui proposée pour assurer les
fonctions de présidente du conseil
d'administration de santé publique
France alors je me présente en quelques
mots
tout d'abord pour dire que j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être nommé en 2021
cambassadrice de la France délégué à
l'environnement je suis issue de la Cour
des comptes mais j'ai débuté ma carrière
dans le privé avant de rentrer dans la
fonction publique et très vite mes
aspirations m'ont portées vers des
missions d'intérêt général qui m'ont
conduit à rejoindre le monde des ONG
d'abord sur le terrain en Thaïlande
auprès de réfugiés et puis un Médecin
sans Frontières et j'ai été pendant
quatre ans directrice financière de
l'organisation Médecins sans frontières
j'ai été également à cette occasion
membre du conseil d'administration de
Médecins sans frontières logistique
chargé de l'achat du conditionnement du
stockage et de l'acheminement des
produits médicaux et non médicaux et
j'ai vécu
lors de mon passage dans cette belle ONG
de très grosse grosse urgences comme
celle du Kurdistan ou du Rwanda qui se
sont ajoutés au programme de travail qui
avait été agréé et voté
je retiens de cette expérience qui pour
moi était absolument fondatrice
l'importance de la coordination en temps
de crise de la sanctuarisation des
équipes de crise du rôle stratégique de
la logistique et de la préparation et de
l'importance aussi du retour
d'expérience en temps réel et de
l'évaluation en temps réel
ayant compris les vertus et touchées aux
vertus mais aussi aux limites de
l'urgence j'ai souhaité
travailler ensuite dans le développement
durable et au sein de la Banque mondiale
où je suis partie j'ai occupé le poste
de directrice de projet dans le domaine
de l'environnement en Amérique latine et
en particulier au Mexique et puis
rentrer en France en 2001 c'est là que
je suis rentré dans la fonction publique
je rejoins la Cour des comptes à la 7e
chambre en charge de l'environnement et
j'ai parallèlement siéger au conseil
d'administration de Médecins sans
frontières pendant 7 ans
en 2007 j'ai à nouveau été appelé sur
des fonctions internationales par le
Programme des Nations Unies pour
l'Environnement en qualité de directrice
générale de la division technologique
industrie et économie avec un
portefeuille assez large qui comprenait
à la fois énergie et climat produits
chimiques et déchets et tout ce qu'on
appelle l'économie verte et l'économie
circulaire
c'était un mandat évidemment passionnant
et qui consistait en fait à agir sur
trois domaines d'une part la stratégie
scientifique de l'organisation est
poussée les limites de ce que peut-être
la recherche et les études scientifiques
dans le domaine de l'environnement
le lancement de grandes négociations
internationales sur la base des
consensus scientifiques qui s'était
dégagé et enfin l'incitation à l'action
des acteurs privés en particulier au
plus tôt et au plus vite avant même les
négociations et après qu'elles aient été
conclues
et de cette expérience je retiens le
véritable intérêt d'un continuum
d'action allant de la science jusqu'à la
mise en œuvre sur le terrain
donc c'est forte de cette expérience que
j'ai été nommée en 2013 directrice des
affaires européennes et internationales
au ministère chargé de l'environnement
essentiellement afin de préparer la COP
21 donc vous avez entendu parler j'en
suis sûr présidé par la France et j'y
étais notamment en charge avec une
équipe interministérielle de
l'engagement des entreprises et de la
société civile ainsi de la négociation
et en particulier des réglementations
européennes
j'en retiens l'importance d'associer les
parties prenantes dès l'origine avant
même la conclusion des accords et pour
mieux mes mettre en oeuvre les éléments
de l'accord
en 2020 j'ai pris la responsabilité du
pilotage et de la mise en oeuvre du plan
de relance poste covid sur son volet
environnement tant que secrétaire
général l'adjointe du plan de relance au
sein du ministère de l'économie et des
finances et enfin sous la responsabilité
directe des deux ministères en charge de
l'environnement et des Affaires
étrangères je suis aujourd'hui
ambassadrice pour l'environnement ce qui
veut dire que je pilote une équipe
interministérielle qui porte les
positions françaises au niveau européen
et international sur des sujets comme la
biodiversité l'eau la forêt ou les
plastiques cette équipe appartient à 5
ministères environnement agriculture
finance recherche et à faire étrangères
ainsi qu'aux différents opérateurs de
ces ministères qui sont concernés
alors dans ce parcours au niveau
international et national je m'en serais
pour terminer une expérience très riche
acquise pardon au sein de la CNIL en
tant que commissaire de la Commission
Nationale Informatique et Liberté en
2019 et 2020 et enfin différentes
expériences acquises au sein de conseils
d'administration de structure publique
par un public ou philanthropiques
alors c'est forte de cette enfin si je
devais citer deux traits qui
caractérisent finalement le fil rouge de
ma carrière et qui me caractérise je
crois que c'est d'une part on aspiration
profonde à identifier mon paraît de
sujets
scientifique pour les traduire en
politique publique ou d'intérêt général
et susciter l'action
et le deuxième c'est celui de la
construction d'opinions et de position
partagée aussi bien en intra française
que en interne national et c'est forte
de cette expérience acquise dans les
dans des
environnements et sur des sujets
relativement complexes que je me
présente devant vous aujourd'hui pour
porter ma candidature ou à la présidence
du conseil d'administration de santé
publique France
le conseil d'administration est central
parmi les instances de gouvernance de
l'agence il statut sur les grandes
orientations stratégiques le programme
de travail le budget mais aussi sur les
règles de déontologie sa composition est
très large
reflétant à la fois l'étendue du
périmètre et son ancrage sociétal
comprend les représentants de 8
ministères
quatre parlementaires dont parmi parmi
vous la sénatrice Véronique Guillotin et
le sénateur Jean-Sol des représentants
des locaux des représentants de
partenaires institutionnels de santé
publique France et de la société civile
alors la présidente du conseil
d'administration de mon point de vue
doit être la garante des discussions
éclairées au sein de ce conseil
d'administration et une partenaire de la
directrice générale de l'agence et de la
tutelle
qui est le ministère de santé bien
évidemment dans les respects des
prérogatives de chacun
j'ai pris connaissance du rapport de la
Cour des comptes bien évidemment sur la
gestion de l'établissement qui
recommande à nous positionnement plus
fort du conseil d'administration sur le
pilotage stratégique de l'agence
avec l'ensemble des membres du conseil
d'administration je souhaite bien
évidemment y prendre ma part dans le
cadre de nos prérogatives
il est en effet essentiel que le conseil
d'administration partage et s'approprie
les orientations stratégiques de
l'agence
et la bonne nouvelle c'est que le
conseil d'administration va être amené à
s'investir dans la préparation du
prochain contrat d'objectifs et de
performance dont la préparation va être
débutée dans les semaines qui viennent
puisque le précédent COP 2018-2022 a été
progrogé d'un an précisément afin de
permettre à la nouvelle directrice
générale et au Conseil et au niveau
conseil d'administration de s'en emparer
je serai évidemment attentive aussi à la
décation des moyens et des missions
comme le relève également la Cour des
comptes et enfin je serai attentive
comme c'est le cas je sais déjà de la
directrice générale aux personnel de
l'agence au risque psychosociaux c'est
une agence qui a été extrêmement
bousculée par le covid et il est
important aujourd'hui qu'elle retrouve
un souffle et un élan je souhaite
également que le conseil
d'administration soutienne l'agence dans
ces efforts de transparence transparence
dans les données d'expertise produites
bien sûr mais aussi au plan budgétaire
comme la relever la Cour des comptes et
je suis évidemment favorable à une
information des assemblées qui
souhaitent identique à celle qui
existait avant le transfert du
financement de santé publique France à
la CNAM
et enfin j'espère que mon regard
légèrement extérieur à l'écosystème de
santé apportera une perspective nouvelle
à santé publique France et contribuera à
identifier les enjeux de demain qu'il
s'agisse bien évidemment des liens entre
santé et environnement mais aussi des
enjeux sanitaires dans les autres mers
de la santé mentale de l'obésité et bien
évidemment des impacts des inégalités en
matière de santé
lors de ces auditions précédant sa
domination pose de directrice générale
Caroline semaille a évoqué son souhait
d'un nouvel élan et à formuler trois
objectifs qu'elle se fixait une
expertise indépendante collégiale au
service des politiques publiques une
agence ouverte et transparente et une
agence qui anticipe et qui innove si
vous m'accordez votre confiance j'aurais
à coeur en tant que présidente du
conseil d'administration de placer cette
ambition là au cœur de nos travaux afin
d'apporter avec l'ensemble des membres
du conseil d'administration le soutien
d'une instance attentive et constructive
pour le bien de l'agence de ces
personnels et de l'ensemble des Français
je vous remercie
Laurence Cohen
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
pour votre je suis là merci pour votre
présentation
vous avez évoqué votre expérience
professionnelle et vous avez vous-même à
l'instant dit que votre regard était
légèrement extérieur au domaine de la
santé donc apportera votre expérience
alors que justement dans laquelle la
santé publique n'apparaît pas central
dans la conduite des fonctions
auxquelles vous êtes candidates en clair
la coloration environnement de votre
curriculum vitae annonce-t-elle une
attention plus marquée au concept une
seule santé one net plus connu sur le
l'intitulée ce qui peut être l'occasion
de préciser enfin car elles en sont les
implications
le rapport de la Cour des comptes vous
l'avez évoqué je rappelle
qu'il insiste notamment sur la faible
impulsion du conseil d'administration
dans le pilotage stratégique de l'agence
qui a donné lieu à peu de débat sur la
prévention de la promotion de la santé
garde davantage sur la réserve sanitaire
comment pensez-vous pouvoir y remédier
voilà si vous pouvez nous en dire un
tout petit peu plus
la création de santé publique française
inspirait des modèles de gestion
publique anglo-saxonne mais sans pousser
la logique à son terme qui aurait requis
davantage de moyens d'une part et
davantage d'autonomie d'autre part
comment voyez-vous le positionnement de
l'agence dans le paysage des agences
sanitaires et quel degré d'autonomie lui
serait utile pour mener à bien ses
missions
quel regard portez-vous également sur la
distribution des missions entre les
différentes agences existantes et je
pense notamment à la dualité entre santé
publique France et lances et sur la
nécessité à voter depuis une quinzaine
d'années de les coordonnées et de les
mettre en réseau pour autant qu'il y ait
lieu de le faire si on adopte une
logique une seule santé
enfin santé publique France est censé
contribuer à l'information à la
formation et la diffusion d'une
documentation scientifique et technique
et au débat public pensez-vous que cela
puisse aller jusqu'à la régulation de
l'éthique scientifique
santé publique France a par exemple
reconnu devant les rapporteurs de la
mission de notre commission sur
l'obésité que les industriels avaient
orienté les recherches pour un style le
doute sur la dangerosité de leurs
produits comment lutter justement contre
les conflits d'intérêts dans ce domaine
je vous remercie très bien vous
souhaitez répondre déjà à ces questions
ou lorsqu'on a des questions aussi je
peux prendre peut-être deux
merci Madame pour votre présentation
et moi j'ai deux questions l'Agence
nationale de santé publique France a
publié le 18 avril dernier une enquête
sur la surveillance des maladies à
caractère professionnels en France sur
la période 2012 et 2018 et si je vous
pose la question c'est que je suis
coteur avec trois de mes collègues qui
sont d'ailleurs aussi dans la commission
des affaires sociales Marie-Pierre
Richer Annick Jacquemet et Laurence
Rossignol donc nous sommes qu'auteur
d'un corps rapporteur
sur justement la santé des femmes aux au
travail et on
constate en fait que il y a de
nombreuses infections qui ne sont pas
déclarés et notamment au sous-déclaré et
notamment tout ce qui concerne les
troubles
musculo-squelettiques alors il y a
différentes cette raison pour lesquelles
il n'y a pas de de déclaration il y a
d'abord à peu près 35% des salariés qui
ne connaissent pas le processus de
réparation il y en a à peu près autant
qui parce que c'est dû à un diagnostic
insuffisant et puis un peu plus de 22%
au refus du salarié parce qu'il a peur
ou elle a peur de perdre de perdre son
emploi et on s'aperçoit que le nombre
est plus important chez les femmes en
tout cas est en augmentation chez les
femmes et moi je voulais savoir ce que
vous envisagez si vous étiez nommé de
faire comme
de oh là là je vais y arriver comme
préconisations gouvernement et notamment
dans le cas de la future loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 pour justement améliorer la santé
au travail et lutter contre des troubles
musculo squelettiques ça c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
ça concerne un récent rapport
corinaire a fait état d'un rapport de la
Cour des comptes vous aussi d'ailleurs
madame qui a été demandé par le par le
Sénat et ce rapport estimé qu'il
pourrait être pertinent notamment un
élargir les facultés d'autonomie de
santé publique France en matière de
gestion des crises sanitaires notamment
pour rendre cette agence plus réactive
et plus autonome est-ce que vous pensez
qu'une telle évolution pourrait
contribuer à mieux prendre en compte et
mieux traiter les pénuries de
médicaments par exemple avec les des un
certain nombre d'outils qui pourraient
être en votre possession en tant que
agence alors là encore pourquoi je pose
cette question c'est parce qu'il y a une
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie de
médicaments dont je suis rapporteur et
là encore au sein de la commission des
affaires sociales il y a plusieurs
commissaires qui siègent et qui sont
présents qui seront attentifs et
attentifs à vos réponses merci d'avance
merci madame la Présidente
vous parlez vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de votre d'un objectif c'était
aussi de travailler sur la question de
l'obésité et
on sait que il y a des études qui
différents instituts qui montrent que la
question de l'obésité coûte à
l'Assurance Maladie au-delà de la
question de la santé publique ça coûte à
l'Assurance Maladie entre 11 et 54
milliards si on ajoute par an si on
ajoute la question de la baisse de
productivité pour ceux qui qui sont
malades de d'obésité on sait aussi que
une fois qu'on est obèse c'est très
difficile d'être traité et de revenir à
un poids normal et donc c'est bien sur
la question de la prévention et en amont
qu'il faut travailler alors ça ne touche
pas directement
uniquement en tout cas la question de la
santé puisque ça passe aussi sur la
l'alimentation sur l'industrie
alimentaire sur le taux que nous
tolérons le taux de fructose que nous
tolérons dans un certain nombre de
produits transformés c'est ultra
transformé mais est-ce que vous avez
dans vos ambitions et dans votre
programme l'ambition justement de faire
un grand plan peut-être un plan obésité
qui touche quand même 5 millions de
enfin ça représente 5 millions de morts
à travers le monde ce qui n'est pas rien
et c'est aussi facteur de différentes
maladies chroniques et de cancer
notamment colorectal et peut-être
d'ailleurs du pancréas il y a certaines
études qui ne laissent à penser que la
question de l'alimentation et l'obésité
pourrait aussi toucher du coup la
question du cancer du pancréas donc
est-ce que vous avez pour ambition de
travailler sur ces sujets là merci alors
madame je vous laisse répondre
merci beaucoup alors je vais répéter ce
que j'ai dit dans mes propos liminaires
à savoir que la présidente d'un conseil
d'administration n'est pas la directrice
de santé publique France elle est elle
préside un conseil d'administration donc
ça vocation c'est d'animer une assemblée
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
collégialité qui existe et qui servent
qui servent à quelque chose mais ça
n'est en rien
mes intentions même si effectivement
j'ai des
aspirations particulières évidemment sur
le sujet santé environnement parce que
je crois effectivement qu'il y a
aujourd'hui on est dans le constat qu'il
y a au fond une santé qui est assez qui
a une grosse interdépendance entre la
vie et la survie des écosystèmes la vie
la survie des animaux et les la santé
humaine mais comme vous l'avez
parfaitement dit tout à l'heure
ça serait utile de l'incarner et de
savoir de quoi on parle c'est à dire
au-delà du constat qu'il y a cette santé
unique concrètement qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire et quels sont les types de
zones auxquelles il faut s'attendre
qu'est-ce que ça voudra dire en terme de
prévention je pense que là on a vraiment
un fil à tirer en particulier compte
tenu du mandat et de la mission de santé
publique France mais certainement pas
seul donc ça sera un œil je dirais un
peu particulier mais je crois que ma ma
fonction est mon parcours font que ce
sera essentiellement la présidence et
l'animation d'une collégialité avec le
fait de pouvoir à certains moments lever
des sujets qui me paraît qui me
paraissent intéressants alors le fait de
le pardon le fait de pouvoir regarder le
prochain contrat d'objectif
assez rapidement sera effectivement
l'occasion de voir comment est-ce que ce
conseil d'administration peut jouer un
rôle un peu plus stratégique
la façon dont j'entends le faire mais je
l'ai pas encore pris contact ni avec mes
collègues du conseil d'administration ni
vraiment avec l'agence mais ce sera
d'essayer de commencer très tôt
lorsqu'on veut établir des consensus en
général c'est pas à la fin qu'on les
établit c'est en se mettant d'accord sur
un certain nombre de base et un certain
nombre de constats partagés donc
j'imagine en tout cas qu'il faudra
commencer par ces constats partagés
écouter ce qui remonte évidemment de
santé publique France de la directrice
générale de son conseil de son comité de
direction écouter aussi le conseil
scientifique et les autres comités de
gouvernance qui ont certainement des
choses à nous dire et essayez au moins
d'avoir un constat entre nous sur les
points qui sont prioritaires à mon avis
la grande difficulté d'une agence comme
santé publique France qui reste
relativement petite au fond par rapport
à l'ampleur du sujet ça va être de faire
des tri
parce que c'est très compliqué lorsqu'on
fait des priorités ça veut dire qu'il y
a forcément des choses qui ne sont pas
prioritaires et donc c'est désagréable
pour les choses qui ne sont pas
prioritaires mais j'espère modestement
pouvoir contribuer à ça ayant moi-même
vécu dans toutes mes expériences
professionnelles l'extraordinaire
difficulté de voir faire plus que ce que
les moyens nous autorisent à faire et ce
qui était prévu en fait voilà donc ça
sera plus facile en tant que présidente
qu'en tant que directrice générale
d'essayer de soutenir ça
en termes de d'autonomie
spécifique de santé publique franchement
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faudra évidemment regarder et aborder
dans ce contrat d'objectif et dans la
discussion avec les tutelles ma
compréhension c'est que le rapport de la
Cour des comptes préconise d'avoir plus
d'autonomie sur un point qui est assez
particulier qui est la gestion des
stocks stratégiques
à savoir est-ce que au moins santé
publique France pourrait faire des
recommandations au gouvernement voir se
saisir elles-mêmes de la reconstitution
de ces stocks stratégiques la grande
difficulté par rapport à ça c'est
évidemment les moyens qui vont avec ça
n'est pas impossible à mon avis je ne
sais pas si c'est souhaitable ce qui
serait souhaitable et ce qui me
paraîtrait souhaitable c'est tout de
même qu'effectivement santé publique
France puisse alerter et je sais qu'elle
l'avait fait enfin je pense sur sur les
masques relativement avant la crise
covid et et pouvoir avoir un vrai
dialogue par rapport à ça
après est-ce que il faut que le santé
publique France puisse se reconstituer
les masques à une certaine hauteur c'est
une discussion qui est possible d'avoir
à mon avis si on a une doctrine d'emploi
une doctrine de constitution des masques
qui est tout à fait clair alors il faut
que santé publique France et une sorte
de volant de trésorerie qui lui
permettra de reconstituer ses stocks
voir de les écouler au fur et à mesure
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
en tout cas qui serait très souhaitable
d'aborder donc au moins clarifier ça
mais je sais aussi qu'il y a une mission
en cours qui regarde la direction la
possibilité de créer une cellule une
direction générale des crises au sein du
ministère de la Santé et qui regarde si
elle doit reprendre seulement la réserve
sanitaire ou peut-être aussi le la
gestion du stock stratégique donc je
pense qu'il faut attendre les décisions
en la matière pour voir ce qui ce qui
serait faisable à mon sens en tout cas
ce qui est tout à fait important c'est
que il y ait qu'une tête si je puis dire
lors des crises c'est vraiment une des
choses qui me paraissent essentielle
c'est que il faut que la coordination
soit claire peu importe d'une certaine
façon où elle est mais il faut qu'elle
existe et qu'elle soit bien clair et moi
je fais partie des gens qui pensent que
en particulier par exemple sur le
terrain c'est clairement un préfet qui
doit prendre la tête lorsqu'il y a une
crise par exemple donc après au niveau
national il faut décider où cela peut
être mais c'est ça qui fait que ça
marche et c'est ça et la préparation et
les bons stocks et des et des exercices
même éventuellement pour pour s'y
préparer
vous m'avez interrogé sur la
coordination avec landeces je sais que
le santé publique français est très
attaché c'est effectivement l'agence qui
est la plus proche pas tout à fait sur
les mêmes sujets tout de même mais
effectivement je crois que les plus
grandes
enquêtes qui sont en cours vont l'être
avec l'ancêtre en tout cas c'est ma
c'est ma compréhension et je ne se suis
pas au courant de du détail de la
coordination qui qui existe avec
landeces mais
j'imagine que en tout cas il faudrait
avoir un certain nombre de mécanismes
pour être sûr que elle est bien claire
et comprit au niveau le plus haut et pas
seulement peut-être au niveau des études
par études
les conflits d'intérêt et l'obésité
alors l'obésité c'est un point dont je
vous ai dit que personnellement en tant
que Présidente je soulèverai ce sujet là
parce qu'effectivement ça me paraît
important je sais que le gouvernement
est en train de je crois comprendre que
le gouvernement est en train de préparer
une feuille de route l'obésité touche
moins de personnes en France que dans
pas mal de pays je crois que c'est à peu
près 15% alors que dans d'autres pays on
est bien au-delà mais ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas s'en occuper et c'est en
progression très forte vous avez
absolument raison et donc c'est un sujet
important alors santé publique France
n'a pas rien fait par rapport à ça parce
que la publication d'une nutriscor qui
je pense est vraiment un des vrais
succès de santé publique France à
marcher alors je sais qu'on peut le
critiquer savoir est-ce que c'est sur la
portion est-ce que c'est au nombre de
grammes etc mais je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui qui marche enfin c'est
assez impressionnant de voir à quel
point les gens le connaissent alors que
c'est assez récent l'enjeu maintenant de
le faire adopter au niveau européen pour
que ce soit une énorme qui s'impose sur
l'ensemble des produits après on peut
évidemment se poser les questions de
savoir est-ce qu'on laisse ce nutriscore
comme un mécanisme volontaire ou est-ce
que on demande son sa mise en oeuvre
obligatoire
ma mon expérience personnelle encore une
fois c'est que le volontariat des
entreprises et ça marche parce que c'est
une façon de les associer dès le départ
mais que souvent effectivement il faut
passer à l'obligation pour
emmener les dernières qui sont un petit
peu réticentes donc avoir ça dépend
vraiment au cas par cas mais en tout cas
oui c'est un sujet qui me qui me paraît
important les sujets de conflit
d'intérêt en la matière sont importants
pas seulement sur les questions
d'obésité évidemment mais mais pas
seulement enfin je pense qu'en matière
de santé c'est un sujet qui est partout
les questions de de conflits d'intérêt
ça fait partie d'émissions du conseil
d'administration de regarder exactement
la façon dont ça se posera à santé
publique France et dont c'est
aujourd'hui
surveillés entre guillemets si vous me
permettez l'expression donc ça ça ferait
partie des choses que nous regarderons
sur la santé des femmes au travail vous
avez tout à fait raison sur le fait que
c'est peut-être des sujets qui sont
sous-estimés et sous-évaluer et on sait
que pour ce qui est de la santé des
femmes il y a d'ailleurs pas seulement
les troubles musculo-squelettiques qui
sont des points sur lesquels les femmes
hésitent à consulter mais mais même on
sait que certaines femmes ne consultent
pas pour des raisons en gynécologiques
par peur des résultats donc on a on a je
pense tout un progrès à faire sur
l'importance du dépistage l'importance
de la prévention et des vrais
campagnes qui soient ciblées il y en a
il y a déjà des campagnes tout à fait
ciblées pour certains publics et en
particulier pour les femmes sur d'autres
sujets il me paraîtrait important je
pense que ce qui est aujourd'hui
la campagne que mène sentait publique
France sur les les examens de milieu de
vie me paraissent être des sujets très
très importants
c'est effectivement essentiellement pour
prévenir la dépendance et donc pour
s'assurer que la fin de vie soit en
bonne santé que l'on dit qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment important de ne pas s'y
prendre à 70 ans mais à 45 je trouve que
c'est un sujet qui est insuffisamment
personnellement en tout cas mis sur la
table et de façon générale je pense que
les les examens aussi bien dans le cadre
de la santé au travail que hors travail
de midi sont des choses qui sont
peut-être à mettre davantage
en exergue pour la bonne santé globale
de la population et surtout d'une
population vieillissante
voilà sur la question de savoir si
l'autonomie permettrait de de faire
quelque chose par rapport à la pénurie
de médicaments je pense que ce sont deux
choses qui sont assez différentes la
pénurie de médicaments ne fait pas
partie des missions de santé publique
France qui s'occupait essentiellement du
stock stratégique
j'espère avoir répondu à la plupart de
vos questions
merci madame la Présidente alors moi
j'avais une question un peu plus
générale donc
l'agence santé publique France qui
poursuit une stratégie de dialogue avec
la société en plaçant je dirais la
démocratie au cœur de son action parce
qu'elle souhaite renforcer l'ouverture
de ces travaux aux acteurs locaux
nationaux société civile évidemment et
donc dans cette stratégie il y a une
vraie volonté de partage de
l'information si vous êtes élu madame
Lemay pensez-vous poursuivre sur cette
stratégie quand même qui va de la
surveillance à la promotion de la santé
je vous remercie
avant que vous répondiez à Brigitte
devez ça moi j'avais une question vous
allez me dire si ça relève de la
présidence ou de la direction lorsqu'on
a fait la commission d'enquête sur le le
début de la crise sanitaire puisque elle
a porté jusque mois d'octobre
entre le début jusqu'au mois d'octobre
2020 on avait noté l'absence de
connaissance des cellules régionales de
santé publique France c'était vraiment
aux abonnés absents personne ne les
connaissait personne ne savait qu'elles
existaient et elles ont été très peu
impliquées dans le début de la gestion
au début de la crise sanitaire est-ce
que vous entendez remédier à cet état de
fait est-ce que c'est dans vos
compétences ou celle de la direction
alors je vais peut-être commencer par là
parce que je pense que c'était
effectivement dans les compétences de la
direction mais ça empêche pas de poser
toutes les bonnes questions au moment où
on établira le plan stratégique et ça
n'empêche pas aussi d'avoir un dialogue
avec la directrice générale sur ce sujet
là je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous et d'ailleurs je dirais peut-être
plus largement santé publique France
n'était pas très connu au tout début de
la crise sanitaire bon à la fois parce
que c'était une agence assez jeune donc
c'était pas un nom qu'on connaissait je
pense que c'est largement différent
aujourd'hui mais c'est ça reste
peut-être vrai au niveau des cellules
régionales alors c'est sans doute dû à
deux choses d'une part le fait que elles
sont essentiellement enfin elles sont
essentiellement elles font aussi de la
remontée d'informations et donc elles
ont moins un rôle direct dans l'action
qui est plus celui des ARS à mon sens et
puis effectivement elles sont le relais
de santé publique France donc je ne sais
pas si elles ont une autonomie en terme
qui est qui est spécifique et puis ça
reste des petites cellules donc c'est un
sujet que je regarderai parce que ça me
paraît important en tout cas on peut pas
dire qu'on a envie d'être auprès des
territoires et de comprendre
particulièrement les populations sans
avoir suffisamment de de moyens à ce
niveau là donc merci madame la
Présidente de ce point
concernant l'information
j'espère avoir compris votre point
moi ça me paraît en fait essentiel parce
que même en tant que personne de la
société civile la première chose qu'on
regarde c'est finalement le site de
santé publique France pour savoir où on
en est
il me semble qu'il a beaucoup évolué
qu'on a beaucoup d'informations depuis
la crise covid en particulier évidemment
sur le covid on a un même niveau de
détails qui est probablement un peu
foisonnant par rapport à ce dont on a
besoin personnellement
je pense avec toute la modestie que je
dois mettre autour de ça parce que là
aussi ça serait à regarder de plus près
mais qu'il est assez largement
perfectible
pour être ce qui me paraît essentiel
c'est que au fond il soit utile et qu'on
s'approprie les messages qui a dedans
aussi bien en termes d'informations mais
que ça déclenche l'action parce que
voilà si on a une information qui ne
n'incite pas à bouger ça ne va pas
changer grand chose voilà donc j'y serai
vraiment particulièrement attentif parce
que j'en suis une utilisatrice et une
utilisatrice parfois un tout petit peu
sur sa faim concernant un certain nombre
d'informations je suis désolé de de le
dire là mais je n'en discuterai
évidemment avec
la Direction de santé publique France
voulait compléter ces questions oui
madame c'était pour préciser préciser
mes questions ma question plutôt
concernant la pénurie de médicaments et
en fait c'est les pénuries d'une manière
d'une manière générale il y a eu un
premier contrat d'objectif et de
performance de santé publique France qui
couvrait la période 2018-2022 et c'est
une période qui s'est avérée plutôt
chargé du point de vue sanitaire entre
d'ailleurs la pandémie et les pénuries
et ma question portait sur le fait que
est-ce qu'il vous semblait pertinent
d'élargir les facultés d'auto saisine de
santé publique France justement en
matière de de gestion des crises
sanitaires et donc à partir du moment où
on parle de gestion des crises sanitaire
il y a des conséquences sur les pénuries
d'une manière générale et les pénuries
aussi au niveau des des médicaments
voilà pour c'était pour préciser le sens
de ma question parce que je pense ne pas
avoir été suffisamment clair je vous
remercie
je vous remercie écoutez c'est une
question que je trouve très intéressante
là aussi je vais vous dire je vais y
réfléchir parce que je pense qu'elle est
plus complexe qu'elle n'en a l'air parce
que de mon point de vue la mission
actuelle de santé publique France c'est
la gestion des stocks stratégiques les
stocks stratégiques sont assez bien
définis
et n'inclut pas forcément
des choses
l'ensemble des médicaments tout venant
qui eux vont dans le circuit normal des
pharmacies donc je sais aujourd'hui
qu'on a des pénuries par rapport à un
certain nombre de médicaments je ne
crois pas que ce soit le rôle de santé
publique France qui a déjà un mandat
très très large ou alors il faut
vraiment revoir et le mandat et les
moyens donc je ne crois pas que ça fasse
partie du rôle de santé publique France
que de résoudre le point particulier
d'aujourd'hui est-ce que il faut
éventuellement élargir le mandat
néanmoins ou tout au moins prévoir dans
le stock stratégique d'autres types de
médicaments
je suis pas sûr que ça soit la meilleure
façon de résoudre la question de la
pénurie des médicaments aujourd'hui
voilà je pense que c'est faisable mais
je suis pas sûr que ça soit la meilleure
chose et donc j'aimerais passer un tout
petit peu de temps à réfléchir avant
d'avoir ma propre opinion et puis
surtout j'aimerais avoir celle de la
directrice générale et du ministère de
la Santé merci
très bien mais écoutez merci Madame le
Maire et
je vous remercions de cette audition et
nous aurons sûrement l'occasion de vous
réentendre lorsque nous recevrons santé
publique France santé
dans beaucoup de missions pénurie du
médicament je suppose que vous avez
entendu santé publique France nous avons
une mission également en cours sur les
données de santé et il y avait une
audition programmée et la Mecque aussi
on va entendre santé publique France
donc nous serons l'occasion de vous
revoir voilà bonne journée à vous bonne
journée à tous et merci vraiment
beaucoup au revoir